es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido iniciamos con los datos más
recientes revelados por la organización
mundial del comercio así es bueno según
el organismo tras la interrupción de los
flujos comerciales por la pandemia las
cadenas de suministro se adaptaron
rápidamente en 2020 la caída del
comercio mundial fue de 5,3 por ciento
pero este año el comercio del mundo
crecerá 10.8 por ciento según la
organización pero advierten de que este
positivismo no deja a un lado la
recuperación desigual por regiones y
tensiones en las cadenas globales de
suministro según las proyecciones de la
organización el producto interno bruto
global que en 2020 cayó un 3,5 por
ciento según cifras del banco mundial
crecerá este año un 5,3 gracias a la
recuperación del comercio de bienes que
aumentará a un 8% mientras que el
comercio de servicios se mantendrá
deprimido al igual que el turismo el
organismo señala que la resiliencia ha
mejorado en esta década si se compara
por ejemplo con otra crisis la crisis
financiera de 2008 según la organización
la recuperación ha sido más rápida que
entonces el organismo señala la que el
cambio climático se ha convertido en un
factor de riesgo para los intercambios
comerciales debido a la frecuencia a la
intensidad y la duración de los
desastres naturales que ahora son un
poco más intensos así es bueno ahora
vamos a grecia donde hay una huelga de
propietarios de restaurantes para pedir
ayudas porque hoy 19 bueno allí atenas
amaneció sin bares cafés y restaurantes
abiertos el gremio se unió para pedir
más ayudas económicas ante las
crecientes restricciones para combatir
la propagación de la pandemia las
medidas prohíben que las personas no
vacunadas puedan sentarse en las
terrazas a menos que presenten una
prueba negativa de kobe 19 mientras que
los espacios interiores están reservados
exclusivamente para los vacunados la
medida excluye a farmacias tiendas de
alimentos y a la propia iglesia según la
federación nacional de restauranteros
durante el primer fin de semana con las
nuevas restricciones el volumen de los
ingresos se redujo entre un 30 y un 50%
mientras que los días laborales han
perdido hasta 70% de ingresos el gremio
pide a las autoridades los exonere de
las devoluciones de las ayudas
financieras que recibieron durante la
pandemia
mantengan las ayudas para el pago de
alquileres además solicitan reducir de
24 hasta el 6 el iva para todos los
servicios que ofertan escuchamos un poco
cuál es la impresión de los
restauranteros allí
y para paul jan steen
hay muchos no vacunados que no salen y
no pueden sentarse en ningún sitio nos
vemos obligados a controlar a toda la
gente si se ha vacunado o se ha hecho un
test rápido lo que tiene consecuencias
para nosotros menos ingresos y menos
sueldos camilo pero eso de más al igual
de la droga mata una situación bien
compleja ahora vamos a eeuu porque
aumentaron las ventas de minoristas en
medio de récord de inflación bueno los
datos de octubre indican que los
estadounidenses anticiparon sus compras
navideñas para evitar encontrarse con
algún tipo de escasez debido a la crisis
de suministro y a la pandemia también el
informe del departamento de comercio
indica que el aumento de la inflación no
frena el gasto incluso cuando la
preocupación por el aumento del costo de
la vida hizo que el sentimiento de los
consumidores cayera a un mínimo de 10
años a principios de noviembre el valor
de las compras minoristas en general
aumentó un 17 por ciento el mes pasado
la mayor cifra en siete meses excluyendo
la gasolina y los vehículos de motor las
ventas aumentaron un 1,4 por ciento en
octubre según analistas los consumidores
están amortiguando la mayor inflación
de cada que se registra en eeuu gracias
a la fortaleza del mercado bursátil y de
los precios de la vivienda así como los
ahorros y las ganancias salariales bueno
ahora vamos con los indicadores
económicos de las jornadas arrancamos
con wall street que cerró positivo tras
conocer unos buenos datos de ventas
minoristas en eeuu en europa algunos
índices bursátiles europeos subieron
impulsados por las acciones del inversor
tecnológico holandés proceso en
latinoamérica el mercado bursátil de
argentina se contrajo un poco más que
ayer por los comentarios de las
calificadoras de riesgo después de las
elecciones el pasado domingo y cerramos
con la cifra del día bueno valentina la
cifra de 735 millones de dólares es
invertir a google en australia el dinero
será destinado a infraestructuras
digitales así como investigaciones para
desarrollar formas de inteligencia
artificial y aprendizaje de máquina sin
duda el futuro así es jorge muchas
gracias por esta ampliación a ustedes
por su sintonía continúen con nosotros
que hay más en france 24
y
[Música]